you should feel von this is Doug from
Florida oh what's up Doug and you know
him one of my early friends man probably
maybe one of my first human friends
this beautiful boy named Doug Hugh vall
and yet he I mean this boy was just
chiseled his head was real chiseled like
his head had been working out like his
head got up early before he even woke up
and went to the damn gym and then came
and got back on his neck for breakfast
you know kind of that kind of boy and I
met him in first grade and he stuttered
he had a stutter something happened to
him been hit by something or you know or
just how to you know had that [ __ ]
giddy II that little hitch and his giddy
and uh he had that you know just
something boy like the Lord had just hit
him in a damn neck with uh with a 1x2
you know nothing heavy but hearty enough
to [ __ ] really sting you know but his
name was Doug homeward Florida it's a
great place get baptized and also fall
into Satanism oh yeah Florida is a great
place man if you like pyramid schemes
and if you hope one of you if you don't
mind one of your kids maybe getting kind
of you know reach that by an adult a
little but they also got Busch Gardens
so you can't win them all baby but yeah
a little bit of Satanism bro gang
brother Homewood brother anyway Matt
just like a random coronavirus man dude
I'm miss shaking people's hands man I'm
a hand shaker I'm just a gentleman and I
want to walk up to another gentleman and
shake that [ __ ] hands
enthusiastically what do you think of a
world without a hand shaking dude
there's been talk of the Japanese bow I
think I'm gonna go with the military
salute much anyway man what's the future
looking like dude gang gang gang Doug
thank you
that's a good question what does it look
like what does the future look like you
know that who's gonna do you know who's
gonna be doing what you know who you
know what's it gonna look like I seen a
guy the other day we have a Halloween
mask on
he's over there looking like damn he's
you know Pokemon and he's be picking
avocados out
it's unique man it's uh yeah hands shake
do I want it I like it you know I like
it we had a guy calling in the past
drippy mitts McGillicuddy this beautiful
fella this dude I think his name might
have been Steven maybe I don't know I
don't have the notes in front of me in a
beautiful young man and he had those
slippery fronts on his paws you know he
had the thing you couldn't even shake
his him because it was just slipping
that in and out of you it would slip in
an idea how do you grip like a damn eel
like a le ting freakin jelly or Jam and
it uh you know so hand shaking the fist
bump it kind of taken over a little it's
human touch human touch it's it's
disappearing man it's been disappearance
you know you're trying to hug somebody
not a key like you were dying you know
they you know it's like a second-degree
assault
and I'll let you hug somebody
they call it love assault this place
over here in Hollyweird what do I want
for the future I like the bow I do think
the bow is pretty cool it's very kind of
Nouveau artsy you know it's a little bit
of like kind of a little bit of it okay
okay you know a little bit of Honor a
little bit of it's a lot of trust to
with the bow because you're taking your
eyes off of your opponent for a second
when you look down you know the
handshake look in the eyes the fist bump
yeah it's the future what do you guys
think the future looks like you think
there's gonna be some things in the
future we're not thinking of that could
disappear or that could be you know none
that not that won't happen anymore I
personally think that we'll just be
taking people's temperatures at places
you know I think that that's not a bad
idea
you know if somebody brings their little
kid a little freaking uh you know Dylan
or whatever his name is little Darla
Darla or whatever little frickin aw you
know little freaking spis you know a
little eat and a little sneaky a seat
then bro and he that's the kind of kid
he'll pick his nose with all nine
fingers brah you know what I'm saying
he'll pick his nose till he pulls one of
his eyes out of it
this little frickin behold and he goes
to the to the slipping slot or whatever
to the UM kids gym Gymboree or whatever
that place over about a highway for four
for six dollars they let your kid bounce
around on a fishing net with a couple of
damn uh beach balls on it or some you
know but they had what the hell am I
talking about I don't know man um but a
lot of places now they take a kid's
temperature and a lot of in a lot of
countries they take a temperature when
you go somewhere oh this kid is dirty
get him out of here
kid hot get that a little hotter get his
hot ass out of here little Heath oh
that's a little hot Heath you know what
I'm saying here here's a little sack ice
or something put it in his pockets and
[ __ ] get his little ass out of here
so I think you will see some stuff like
that what do you guys think you're gonna
see nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one watch
this one